this animation is brought to you by the
smart image base a subscription website
where you can download thousands of
medical images and videos to use in
lectures courses presentations
professional training and more for more
information click on the link in the
description
please watch the entire video before
emptying the urine collection bag or
cleaning your catheter
this video will teach you how to empty
the urine collection bag attached to
your suprapubic catheter and how to
clean the catheter
a suprapubic catheter is a thin rubber
tube that runs from your bladder
through a small incision in your lower
abdomen to a bag that collects the urine
[Music]
a balloon filled with water holds the
catheter in place
caring for your suprapubic catheter
involves emptying the collection bag
and cleaning your incision
to empty your suprapubic catheter you
will need a clean cloth or paper towels
to clean up spills
disposable gloves
and a waste basket
[Music]
be sure to keep the urine collection bag
lower than your hips to allow the urine
to drain out of your bladder and into
the bag
step one wash your hands with soap and
water and then dry them
step 2 put on disposable gloves
[Music]
step 3 hold the bottom of the collection
bag over a toilet
step 4 open the drain valve
urine will begin draining from the bag
step 5 close the valve
step 6 remove your disposable gloves and
throw them away in the waste basket
step 7 wash your hands with soap and
water and then dry them
now you will begin cleaning your
catheter
you will need a plastic bag a waste
basket a clean washcloth clean paper
towels cotton swabs or cotton balls
disposable gloves
a 4 inch by 4 inch split dressing gauze
and dressing tape
[Music]
be careful not to pull on the tubing
when cleaning your catheter
step one wash your hands with soap and
water and then dry them
step two put on disposable gloves
step 3 gently remove any old dressing
materials around your catheter incision
put the old dressing in a plastic bag
and throw it into the waste basket
step 4 remove your disposable gloves and
throw them away in the waste basket
step 5 wash your hands again with soap
and water and then dry them
step 6 put on disposable gloves
step 7 wash the skin around your
incision using a washcloth and warm
soapy water dry your skin completely
with a clean paper towel
[Music]
step 8 wash about 4 inches of the
catheter tube where it enters your skin
with a cotton swab or ball and warm
soapy water
[Music]
start at your incision and wipe away
from your body
do not wipe toward your incision
step nine
place a new four inch by four inch split
dressing gauze at your incision and
around the catheter tube
tape the gauze in place using dressing
tape
[Music]
be sure to clean your suprapubic
catheter at least once a day
contact your surgeon if
you have any questions about your
suprapubic catheter you have chills and
your temperature is 101 degrees
fahrenheit or higher
your bladder feels full but you see no
urine draining into the bag
your incision is bleeding or swollen
urine is leaking around your catheter
your urine is cloudy has a foul odor you
see grit or stones in your urine or you
notice bright red blood in your urine
it is normal to see a small amount of
blood or pink tinged urine after some
procedures
[Music]